الغناء الغناء سبيل السعاده كبارا كنا او
صغارا مواهب غنائيه في عمر الزهور هذه
المواهب الغنائيه التي في عمر الزهور وتحت
اشراف الفنانه اللبنانيه العالميه ثاني
قسيس تقدم صوتا للحب والانسان تحت اسم
كورال هرموني اليوم مشاهدينا سنكون معا
لنسمع اصوات عزباء جعلت رسالتها في
الفن مع الانسان ولاجله
معنا الان مشاهدينا في الاستوديو روان
البينا وهي من المشاركين في الكره اهلا بك
يا روان معنا صباح الخير صباح الغناء روان
معنا دقيقه اول اشي انا سمعت انه انت طبعا
مشاركه في هذا الكورال والسبب اللي شاركتي
فيه علشان بنتك تدخل فيه كمان
لتشجيع بنتي انه تدخل على الكورال وحتى
يكون عنا هوايه من نميه مع بعض
سعاده الغناء ينبوع الفرح
بعدين الغناء
تغيير
بالمود وبخليك من جوا تعطي شي من قلبك
اي حدا يغني انا صوتي نشاز اي حدا يغني
لاني صوته حلو لانه لما تدخل بالكورال
بيكون عندك تدريب نحن باكاديميه تانيه
مدربين عنا اساتذه غناء اساتذه موسيقى
بعلمه مش بس الغناء بس كمان العزف على
الالات الموسيقيه الجميل جدا انه انتبهت
انه في تنوع باعمار المشاركين اغلبهم
صبايا في شويه او مش صبايا بنات وفي شويه
صبيان ولكن يعني احجامهم واعمارهم صغيره
جدا شفت حدا مثلا اربع سنين خمس سنين اربع
سنين لا عمرك 99 اذا بحبوا يكونوا موجودين
معنا وفي عندنا كمان جنسيات مختلفه وفي
عندنا كونسرت بثلاثه عيون يونيو
ان شاء الله حنكون حاضرين اذا في يوم
السبت الجاي في مول الامارات طيب حنشوف
تغني يلا خلينا نسمع
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
حبيبتي
[موسيقى]
مناصير طريقنا ينتهي
تجعلك قلبك ينبض اخرى
والحياه لتس
[موسيقى]
سناخذ
القرار ونغير
المسار هذا ما
[موسيقى]
نحن
التغيير
سوف نبني وطنا الوطن
الدمار نحن
التغيير
نحن التغيير
نحن الابطال نحن الامل والاستمرار
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
عبيدا
[موسيقى]
شيء
اقف على الشعر
[موسيقى]
النفسيه
طريقنا ينتهي
[موسيقى]
يجعل قلبك ينبض مره اخرى
والحياه تشتهي
[موسيقى]
سناخذ
القرار
ونغير المص
[موسيقى]
الح هذا ما
نكون نحن
[موسيقى]
ونرقد
الدمار نحن الدليل
نحن الدعيم
[موسيقى]
احمد هو الاستمرار
عبيده
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
خالص خالص مش عايزه
الجيش
[موسيقى]
حبيبه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات